et josé espinosa il et gilet jaune josé
spinoza bonjour merci d'être re en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
parmi les manifestants contre la loi
sécurité globale cet après midi dès
gilet jaune alors en quoi il était
important que le mouvement soit
représenté cet après midi il a écouté ça
fait deux ans que le mouvement se
poursuit samedi après samedi on égrène
toutes les semaines des manifestations
des prises de position pour dire que ça
ne va pas puisque les revendications que
nous avions misé le 17 novembre 2010 8
n'ont toujours pas trouvé solution
positive et donc ça continue et le
deuxième aspect c'est que nous avons
subies pendant les deux ans nous avons
suivi les violences policières les plus
comment dire les plus alarmantes connu
depuis depuis la guerre alors voilà sur
l'eau il ya le j'enlève guidant les
questions liées à la guerre d'algérie
vivait sur le plan social c'est là la
pire répression que nous ayons subis
avec je le rappelle 800 gilet jaune
toujours en prison avec des dizaines et
des dizaines des borniers avec des gens
notre hacker avec des gens qui ont été
mutilés à vie et avec 2 moore à l'orge
est à dire donc justement jauzein
espinosa cette question des violences
policières elle a été mise
particulièrement en avant alors des
manifestations de gilet jaune des vidéos
de journalistes ou des vidéos de citoyen
permis à montrer des abus d'usagé
excessif de la force par les forces de
l'ordre
quels sont vos inquiétudes aujourd'hui
l'inquiétude laisse est justement le
fait que la loi va couvrir les violences
policières en empêchant que les
journalistes et notamment ceux qui sont
les
on les appelle ceux qui sont un
freelance parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
journalistes en freelance
ils vont ils ne pourront plus développé
leur vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux et
pas seulement les freelances mais le
simple citoyen comme moi par exemple je
peux prendre les vidéos aujourd'hui je
peux en faire j'en fais d'ailleurs et je
pourrai plus les maîtres sur les réseaux
et donc l'information est l'expression
la liberté d'expression vont être
altérée et même complètement réduite à
néant
et c'est contre ça que nous conter nous
protestons aujourd'hui moi j'étais tout
à l'heure à la manifestation pour ça
pour dire non il faut arrêter c'est
cette loi liberticide qui est en train
de pourrir la seule le la situation
d'aujourd'hui est alors je voudrais dire
à cet égard que monsieur d'arman n est
pire que monsieur castaner or déjà
monsieur castaner l'appeler le ministre
la castagne avec que darmanin il est
beaucoup plus subtile beaucoup plus fin
beaucoup plus intelligents mais donc
beaucoup plus dangereux on voit tout ce
qui est en jeu explique jésus espinosa
on voit en direct sur ces images que la
tension commence à monter elle est un
petit peu redescendue la forte
heureusement maintenant néanmoins qu est
ce que vous craignez pour les les jours
les mois à venir vous vous craignez les
le gouvernement vient de donner un blanc
seing à la police pour qu'ils matraque
sans problème et donc on va avoir des
violences que plus grave encore que
celle que nous avions jusqu'à maintenant
en gros c'est avec la loi est-ce que ce
que fait le gouvernement c'est qu'ils
viennent de mettre dans la loi les et
les éléments dont il a usé pendant deux
ans par exemple les drones assaf état
existe déjà c'est pas un truc nouveau
les toutes les haines les grenades
offensive les et vous défensive mais qui
sont offensive quand même qu'ils font de
même chacun le même résultat
les ailes le [ __ ] les armes non létales
paraît-il elles sont toujours en
circulation et le sont utilisés et
depuis deux ans c'est à dire qui à bien
y couvre le gouvernement veut couvrir
les la police pour faire une sale
besogne
tout ça pour empêcher les l'opposition
par des manifestations ou par d'autres
rassemblements parce qu'il ya pas que
des manifestations qui sont réprimées
c'est simple rassemblement l'ont été
aussi et est ce que vous comprenez en
tout cas que qui effectivement certains
policiers lorsqu'ils sont filmés après
que leur visage leur adresse soit
montrée sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce que vous comprenez que cet aspect
là il est aussi à prendre en compte mais
tout à fait mais ça s'est passé c'est
pas l'essentiel de ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux sociaux
moi qui suis sur les réseaux sociaux je
vais vous dire gg
jamais encore vu comment dire une vidéo
me demandant de donner une adresse où
l'image d'un policier par contre ce que
j'ai vu c'est des gens qui étaient
matraqués ghazi avec les lacrymo droit
dans les yeux oui ça j'en ai vu beaucoup
pendant ces ne faut pas inverser les
choses alors lui en tous les cas on a
intérêt à faire en sorte que la liberté
d'expression ni la lide ce que j'appelle
la liberté tout court doit être défendu
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est qu'entre les
manifestants d'aujourd'hui
demain ce sera contre les autres et
pourtant il y aura beaucoup de gens qui
vont réclamer des
et pour le progrès sociaux je pense par
exemple des commerçants les artisans et
aujourd'hui sont en difficulté quand il
monte parce qu'au bout d'un moment
pour le moment ils sont assez gentil
moment justement je vous ai josé
espinosa justement le mouvement d'elie
gilet jaune vous le rappeliez à deux ans
avec la crise sanitaire notamment
on a bien vu qu'il avait un peu perdu de
son élan pour autant est ce que vous
sentez le mouvement encore vivace à mais
il est vivace et depuis toujours le la
seule question qui est posée mais que je
pose moi depuis longtemps c'est que le
ca va s'élargir du rad est ce que
j'aimerais appeler les gilets
multicolores nous aurons les gilet jaune
mais déjà aujourd'hui nous avons les as
et les enseignants nous avons les
secteurs sanitaires nous avons les
avocats nous avons les commerçants les
artisans
nous avons donc des ouvriers nous avons
tout un tas de catégories qui sont à
l'action alors ça va continuer ça va se
développer parce que la politique de
macron va contribuer à mettre en voix
dans la rue tout un tas de gens qui n'y
croyaient pas aujourd'hui et qui
pensaient d'ailleurs ce qui est marrant
de mon point de vue c'est que
aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens qui ont
voté macron au premier tour sont
aujourd'hui mes copains de la politique
qu'il développe mais du coup est ce que
il ya un dialogue qui encore encore
possible selon vous avec le gouvernement
en tout cas qu'est ce que vous attendez
aujourd'hui les des membres du
gouvernement avec cette crise sanitaire
et cette crise économique que nous
sommes en train de vivre dialogue pour
crédit alors il faut être deux pour le
moment du côté du gouvernement
c'est vous pouvez causer mais c'est ça
m'intéresse beaucoup
mais c'est moi qui fais white et donc
c'est pas avec une politique comme ça
qu'on va vers un dialogue je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je vais vous dire mon
sentiment profond
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est temps de
se débarrasser de ce régime
le problème c'est qu'au ça sera dans 18
mois mais dans 10
- faudra prendre le bus le thème de
vente
il faudra pour mettre à bas macro et
c'est se dire merci j'osais espinosa
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci merci à vous je rappelle que vous
êtes gilet jaune